t
pour les droits des animaux. Ilg
terme pour certains chats quand
ils subissent un délestage. De
changements de comportement.
- La pratique est courante.t dee
les pousser à ne pas le faire.
Tant que c'est prévu. C'est
- Beauco
- En plus du dégriffage
Le nouveau reglèment interdira
aussi la coupe de la queue ouuuu
des oreilles pour des raisons
esthétiques.
LUCIE HÉNAULT, vétérinaire,
fondatrice magazine Flair & Cie
le bien-être animal. Maintenant,
si on parle avec notre tête,
bien, on comprend qu'il y a
toute une législation derrière
ça. Il faut laisser le temps
leur travail par rapport à ça.
Mais ce qu'on peut retenir,
c'est que c'est un pas dans
la bonne direction.
- Une nouvelle leg
sans conséquence.
- J'ai l'impressio
va peut-être avoir quelques
abandons pour des chats qui
vont déterait ainsi
le pas d'autres provinces
comme lerunswick,
la Colomie-Britannique ou
l'Île-du-Prince-Édouard qui
aux domestiques tout
comme une quarantaine de pays.
ielle Kadjo,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.